es ist jetzt ein ganz großer
schauspielstar zugeschaltet ben becker
begrüße ich jetzt ganz herzlich
wir haben ihre schwester meret becker in
diesem video gesehen sie sind uns jetzt
auch zugeschaltet was ging ihnen durch
den kopf wo hat die kunst und ich sehe
sie stecken ob man auch mitten in der
kunst ihre grenzen
einen wunderschönen guthaben erstmal aus
ludwigsburg zugeschaltet bin mir haben
drehen wird vermessen und trallala es
ist so dass die kollegen haben wir
versucht auf meine schwester das thema
auf eine ironische art und weise zu
behandeln das ging daneben
sie wurden auf unangenehme art und weise
politisiert und in eine ecke gedrängt
die vier ich glaube gar nicht dafür
sagen wir künstler absolut nicht
unterstützen
wir lassen uns nur wegen einer gewissen
kritik an dem wie man mit dieser
pandemie umgeht und das vom grundgesetz
verändert usw
wir lassen uns nicht in eine ecke
drängen mit der wirklich absolut nichts
zu tun haben nur der menschliche umgang
miteinander
der muss doch wie hat herbert grönemeyer
kinder haben die macht gesagt ja der
muss doch gegeben sein wir sind ja alle
nicht doof also lasst uns vernünftig
miteinander umgehen
ein freund von mir sagte neulich das
thema nochmal einer sowas wie
nationalsozialismus sei von deutschem
boden aus nicht vorstellbar mittlerweile
bin ich folge ich diesen gedanken weil
diese weise miteinander umzugehen wird
immer bösartiger und immer unangenehmer
und das kann nicht sein
wir haben es mit einer schlimmen
pandemie einer krankheit zu tun weltweit
wir sind
was waffenverkäufe angeht stellen wir
auf weltrangliste 3 ja aber
krankenhausbetten sind angeblich nicht
mehr da mensch dann geht noch mehr geld
für die krankenhäuser und für die alten
menschen pflegebedürftigen und so weiter
raus und hört auf panzer zu verkaufen
und helft uns diese scheiße zu
überwinden ja und gerade uns künstler
trifft im land der dichter und denker
guten tag herr becker vielen hat zu
lange für diesen beitrag was glauben sie
denn google deutschland kritisieren sie
sagen wir brauchen alle einen toleranten
umgang miteinander wir wünschen uns
glaube ich alle dass diese panne seien
miteinander umgehen
wir sind ja nicht dumm wir müssen uns
gerne haben das kann doch nicht sein
dass ich hier am set sitte und darf
nicht mehr auf porzellantellern essen
sondern aus plastikschüssel die wird so
geteilt werden
ja das stimmt denn das ich bin hier in
baden württemberg das machen die bei
porsche in der kantine und bei mercedes
in der kantine das stiften wahl der ich
gründe gerade eine neue drastik insel
das kann doch nicht sinn der sache sein
kinder redet doch man künftig mit man
das aber ändert nicht das grundgesetz
und sagt ihm dürfen das und die das
nicht
ab morgen ist alzheimer nicht mehr
schwul oder was was geht mich seid
vernünftig und luftig also nützlich und
liebt und man kann sie dann die kollegen
verstehen dsm unter dem druck dass sie
in eine rechte ecke in einer afg nahe
ecke in einer alu hut verschwörer
theorie ecke gedrängt werden das vierte
video zurück kann sie verdienen als die
jetzt sehr video zurückziehen ist es
können sie verstehen dass sie sich dafür
entscheiden dann doch lieber still zu
bleiben weil dieser druck so groß sollte
nicht still bleiben nur wir lassen uns
nicht in die rechte ecke drängen
das geht nicht wir haben fragen und
diese fragen sind absolut ist
existenziell und berechtigt das heißt
aber nicht
dass ich mich in eine rechte ecke
drängen lasse ja böhsen onkelz audi
rechts aber wenn ich rechtssicher bin
ich auf der anderen straßenseite
das ist so einfach zu
instrumentalisieren
und ich glaube das ist nicht der plan
von uns künstlern von jan josef liefers
von martin brambach von meret becker
von ulrike folkerts von nico auf direkt
und von ben becker wir lassen uns nicht
instrumentalisieren und erst recht nicht
lassen wir uns in die rechte ecke
schieben
wir sagen nur passt auf wie wir diese
zeit miteinander umgehen was ist für sie
herr becker jetzt in diesen zeiten als
künstler als schauspielstar die
schwierigste herausforderung vor der sie
stehen
das ist dass ich nicht auf die bühne
darf das schlimmste das einem grüß ich
bin fast pleite aber noch nicht aber das
ist nicht ich darf meinen beruf nicht
ausüben das ist wie wenn sie einem maler
die pinsel und die fahrer die wegnehmen
das tut weh wer hat ihnen das video von
meret becker von ihrer schwester
gefallen
ich frag den versuch toll und ich finde
es traurig dass ich heute morgen um 9
uhr mit meiner schwester telefonieren
musste und wie sehr traurig war weil sie
gesagt hat wenn rede nicht mit max und
springer verlag die schieben uns in die
rechte ecke darf ich gesagt doch marie
kette erst recht weil ich muss meine
schwester verteidigen weil ich sie liebe
wie alle menschen sie kann sich so in
meinem beruf das schöne an unserem beruf
ist dass wir auch sicherlich niemanden
in irgendeiner rechte oder sonst eine
ecke schieben wollen gegen das ist die
aufgabe journalisten und deswegen die
springer liebt liebt sie für diesen satz
und absolut das sehe ich das sehen wir
hier allem hauses unsere aufgabe als
journalisten wie geht es jetzt weiter
wie konnten sie ihre schwester
sie müssen schon ich bedanke mich für
das gespräch herr becker ich danke
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren